amateurs de bières de microbrasseries
silvio rapporte ces bouteilles vides à
l'épicerie mais l'épicier au repas tout
de les reprendre
pourtant un commerce qui vend des
contenants consignés québec doit
reprendre toutes les bouteilles qui ont
cette inscription
peu importe leur format ces contenants
sont recyclés ou frais de l'industrie
mais sur certaines des bouteilles de
silvio il est simplement inscrit dépôts
et sur d'autres il n'y a rien en
principe ces bouteilles sont reprises
par les microbrasseurs qui eux les
réutilise messi l'épicier ne vend pas ce
type de bouteille
peu importe la marque il a le droit de
la refuser inversement si silvio lui
rapporte qu'une bouteille identique à
une autre que l'épicier 20 l'épicier
douala reprendre mais ce n'est pas tout
certaines bouteilles de silvio porte la
mention consignes et là où la valve
prescrits celle-là silvio au québec
personne n'en veut en était là dans le
bac de recyclage
le fin mot de l'histoire pour bien
comprendre les consignes il est
peut-être préférable que vous soyez à
jeun